you are watching TV hi welcome to
another ColdFusion video ten years ago
the word fake would normally be
associated with plastic surgery or cheap
DVDs but as the world moved more and
more online and anyone anywhere can
create and publish a story or an image
we often have to ask is this fake in
this episode we'll take an interesting
look at the rise of deep fakes is the
kind of technology that could
potentially save hundreds of thousands
of dollars but also has some real-world
consequences let's dive in but first I
just want to take a second to give a
shout out to the sponsor of this video
audible so I know most of you guys in
the northern hemisphere approach in the
summer season you'll be spending more
time outdoors at the beach
road-tripping whatever but why not make
the most of your summer days by
consuming content at the same time
audible is a great way to do that with
an unmatched range of books on every
topic including science and technology
audible is offering you guys a free
audiobook with a 30 day trial membership
just head on to www.nasa.gov the acne
logo on it it was put on digitally and
it can be removed just as easily drops
of water can be put in the space left by
the erase logo by simply picking up
existing drops of water and duplicating
them a few centimeters away
the potential for the system goes a lot
further than that operators say they can
take a group photograph for instance and
rearrange the people's heads on
different shoulders in such perfect
detail it would be impossible to tell a
change had been made it makes you wonder
a picture may still be worth a thousand
words but what about that old saying the
camera never lies video however remains
sacred if you have someone on video then
you have the perfect backup for any
quote idea or action that you want to
attribute to that person but this is all
about to change
thanks to the rise of deep fakes so what
are deep fakes
deeper fakes are altered videos usually
a famous people produced by newer
networks
it could be superimposing a face onto a
body so it looks like they're doing
something that they never did well you
can take some speech and then alter the
content making the face movements match
the new audio that you've put in even
before deep fakes you've probably seen
the basic system at work it's what
powers those goofy snapchat filters
where you can have the googly eyes or a
demon face the tech behind this face
detection is not exactly a new
technology even old digital cameras had
this feature in 2001 Paul viola and
Michael Jones proposed a real-time face
detection system now known as the viola
Jones object detection framework
basically this framework allows machines
to easily detect faces by using the
differences in brightness between pixels
today we still use this basic premise
but there are many new steps that have
been added together they combine to
create computer vision the viola Jones
part is used for high level detection of
the basic markers of a face but snapchat
trained their system on many hundreds of
faces that were manually marked with
points to show the borders of lips eyes
nose and face the trained application
can then take a point mask and shift it
to match your individual face based on
the data that it's getting from your
camera at 24 frames per second this is
also you can keep those dog ears in
place or do that Facebook snapchat
technology was mostly built on the
experience gained by a Ukrainian company
luxury in 2015 and it cost them one
hundred and fifty million dollars to
acquire
so in three short years things have
advanced rapidly we know that film
studios have been able to swap faces for
years
Oliver Reed did it for some scenes in
Gladiator and a young Carrie Fisher
appeared again in Star Wars rogue one
but for these the process is long and
expensive here's how they did it for the
grand moff tarkin character in Star Wars
the process we would take - to create a
show like this the first thing we do is
we shoot the live-action play
photography this is with guy Henry as I
perform on set and he's dressed in full
costume he has what we call a head
mounted camera rig which is designed
solely for capturing his facial
performances of charm this is the
earliest test is the first time we ever
saw guys motion transferred onto guys
model and then put on to Tarkan's first
like an early like this the problem is
Cushing's performance and Henry's
performance didn't always match that
required painstaking sometimes frame by
frame adjustments constantly refining
the most subtle details you can imagine
this method took 18 months and would've
cost a small fortune and in just my
opinion the results are within the realm
of a video game cutscene today though
free apps like fake app make CGI face
mapping a simple tool that almost anyone
can operate to drive this point home
here's a side by side video comparison
of Princess Leia in rogue one one
sequences painstakingly made at a cost
likely in the hundreds of thousands with
the use of an insanely expensive
computer the other one was done in 30
minutes by an average guy on an average
computer for free yes there's obviously
differences but honestly are those
differences worth hundreds of thousands
of dollars the previous scene was done
with a program called fake app and
here's how it works so you want to swap
the face of Lois Lane in the Superman
film with the face of Nicolas Cage the
first step is to select your source
video then find a whole range of images
of Amy Adams who acted Lois Lane and
also a whole range of images of Nicolas
Cage all of these images together serve
as the AIS training data you don't even
have to manually download the images one
by one the app has an automatic script
that downloads all the images at once
for you
the second step is to get rid of the
parts of the images that we don't want
like objects in the scene when this is
done it's easier for face detection the
third step is just to let the AI do its
magic a neural network model gets to
work learning how to recreate a given
face from the images it has here's a
snapshot example from within faker the
first six columns show face a being
transformed into face B and vice versa
and the last six columns within each
group of three images the leftmost is
the original image the middle image is
the model trying to redraw the original
image and the rightmost is the predicted
transformation the network then outputs
the score detailing the amount of error
there is within the transformations when
the score is sufficiently low
congratulations you have a good quality
deep fate now it's possible to map one
face onto another face in real-time
video using just images a video is just
a collection of rapidly changing images
at around 24 to 30 times a second so
this makes sense when you think about it
technology like this cuts down the cost
and effort by many orders of magnitude
putting powerful tools in the hands of
the everyday person but what about the
negatives unsurprisingly there's been a
lot of fake adult content created or
existing porn scenes have celebrity
faces imposed all you need to do is find
an actress with a similar build and then
most of the work has done for you by the
algorithms the adult sector was one of
the biggest driving forces behind the
recent surge of fake videos however
arguably the biggest danger we face is
in politics politicians are on camera a
lot often in quite a fixed position like
standing at a podium or sitting for an
interview this makes them incredibly
easy subjects for deep fakes all you
need to do is record any actor making
the facial movements you want and then
you could map these onto a politician
altering the way they react or even what
they say and you might be thinking so
you'll still need a really good
impersonator to match the voice well
well not for long at an Adobe conference
in 2016
zu Jin introduced voco this tool was
basically Photoshop for audio he uses a
learning algorithm to analyse the speech
patterns and convert it into text with
just 40 minutes of speech it will have
examples of almost every sound of that
voice in that language so to recreate
the new vocal audio or
to do is type we can just type the word
dogs here and and I kiss my wife and my
dogs
[Music]
here's more his more we can actually
type something that's not here so let's
remove the word my here and also just
type the word Jordan and I kiss Jordan
my dog's we're not just going to do with
words we can actually type small phrases
so let's say okay so we remove those
words and we do three time and play back
and I kissed Orton three times
[Applause]
recently researchers at the University
of Washington managed to convincingly
make Obama say anything the AI managed
to actually specifically learn how
Obama's mouth moved the heart of our
method is a recurrent neural network
that transforms input audio to a
time-varying mouth shape now most of us
don't get our health care through the
marketplace to get it through our job or
through Medicare or Medicaid then we
synthesize mouth texture and what you
should know is that thanks to the
Affordable Care Act your coverage is
better today than it was before
next we enhance details and teeth I'll
have free preventive care there are no
more annual or lifetime limits on
essential health care finally we blend
the mouth texture onto a retimed target
video and match the pose women can get
free checkups and you can't get charged
more just for being a woman
young people can stay on a parent's plan
until they turn 26 and the
infrastructure that creates good new
jobs not to mention the job training
that helps folks earn new skills but we
can't even create an Obama video from
voice impressionists here we go
President Barack Obama when you giving a
speech make sure you use a lot of pauses
and speak at a very weird tammer up and
down down and up so thinking about it if
you can make a politician say anything
you want think about the impact that
this could have so in a broader sense if
these videos become commonplace
perhaps if you give some ground for
politicians to actually deny something
that they actually said and then it
becomes a question of how to even trust
any evidence given and this leads us to
our final question how do you prove that
a video is real it's extremely difficult
if you can get a fake video in the raw
format that it was uploaded in there are
telltale signs that you can find every
digital recording device has its own
unique algorithms that decide what
information is kept you can't store
every pixel of every frame it's just too
much data so cameras bashed little
groups together if they're very close in
color for example and this acts as a
sort of fingerprint for the camera model
so an expert will be able to tell where
this has been altered
but the thing is once this video has
been uploaded and downloaded a few times
it's hard enough to find in the first
place but it'll be almost impossible
once it's traveled around the internet
sometimes they'll be telltale glitches
when a face moves in a slightly strange
way or if 3d mask doesn't exactly match
up with the movements of the head but
the software will keep getting better
making mistakes harder to find so is
there any hope well yes there's a couple
of things that may save us in the future
for example we can rely on AI to fight
AI that is an AI that specifically been
built to detect fakes let's walk through
this idea if an AI is given a training
set of fake and real videos and is told
which one's a fake and which ones are
real
perhaps after enough training you'll be
able to tell fake videos with better
accuracy than we can
another solution could be verified
videos stored in a blockchain so that
they can't be altered and also we'll
know that they're real when they're
taken from a particular block in the
blockchain so that's kind of where we
stand right now with great power comes
great responsibility and deep fakes has
a highly positive side but as you can
see there's a negative side as well so
I'm going to pass the question on to you
guys what are your thoughts on deep
fakes let me know in the comments
section below
I can kind of see the maturity level of
a comment section dropping already but
anyway this is Ben - gogo you've been
watching cold fusion if you just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe I'll see you again soon for
the next video
Jia's guys have a good one
[Music]
cold
be thinking
you